ciclo olímpico de américa ha comenzado
en valledupar con los juegos
bolivarianos allí está france24 con su
enviado especial luis méndez y con él
hablamos de una jornada en la que
colombia ha comenzado a labrar su
ventaja al frente del medallero
louis le damos la bienvenida y le
preguntamos dónde ha estado la clave de
esta cosecha colombiana
[Música]
25 medallas fueron disputadas el día de
hoy y 11 de ellas fueron ganadas por
colombia donde estuvo la clave en los
deportes de combate allí colombia se
hizo de la mayor cosecha a lo largo del
día con tres medallas de oro de siete
que se disputaron en el kárate al tiempo
que también consiguió tres medallas de
oro de siete disputadas en el judo por
eso fue importante este despegue que
tuvo la representación colombiana a lo
largo de la jornada pero además
consolidó su dominio en disciplinas en
las cuales son tradicionalmente
dorados sus atletas como es el caso del
ciclismo y también el patinaje de
velocidad en ciclismo consiguieron el
112 a través de la ruta masculina
mientras que en el patinaje de velocidad
también completaron el doblete tanto en
masculino como en femenino en la
modalidad de los 10.000 metros con
eliminaciones
el patinaje allí gabriela rueda y
también andrés gómez consiguieron la
medalla dorada pero conversamos con
ellos sobre sus emociones sus
experiencias y sobre lo que será su
futuro luego de estos juegos
bolivarianos pues esta medalla de bronce
tiene mucho significado para mi país
hace años que no habíamos obtenido una
medalla en unos juegos bolivarianos creo
que estoy primera atleta de venezuela-
del patinaje que le puede brindar una
medalla a venezuela y de verdad es de
mucho significado esta medalla está muy
contenta de brindarle el resultado a mi
país este oro es para ellos para adiós
para mi familia y muy contenta si había
más no nomás como presión sino teníamos
como ese honor ese privilegio de carl
este este triunfo a colombia y en casa
louis esta ha sido una jornada de
revanchas para colombia particularmente
en la esgrima en el concretamente en el
florete cierto
así es
recordemos que en los pasados juegos de
santa marta en el año 2017 se le escapó
la presea dorada a la delegación de
colombia en el florete masculino pero
este año frente a venezuela consiguieron
hacerse de esa medalla que no pudieron
lograr en los juegos de santa marta esta
vez estuvieron cerrados combates frente
a la delegación venezolana a un score
final de 45 por 40 y a lo largo de cada
una de las presentaciones la ventaja
mayor fue sobre el final con esos 5
puntos que logró la representación
colombiana previo a eso fueron dos para
venezuela 3 para colombia nuevamente el
venezuela y así estuvieron alternando
cada una de las diferentes
presentaciones hasta cumplir el
recorrido completo sin embargo venezuela
pudo darle vuelta a la página con la
espada por equipos o femeninas donde se
hizo de la presea dorada eso sí dejando
en el camino a colombia que se quedó con
la blanda y república dominicana- equipo
que vencieron
en la semifinal a 45 por 26 particular
mención tuvo esta medalla de oro para
santiago pachón recordemos que el
colombiano venía a buscar la medalla de
oro acá en su tierra sin embargo lucas
lugar de perú se le atravesó y le
impidió conseguir esa presea dorada de
lo dejó con la medalla de bronce
recordemos que luchar disputó la presea
dorada frente al venezolano antonio leal
pero escuchemos que dijo santiago pachón
luego de conseguir ese triunfo en el
florete por equipos nada muy importante
creo que es un desahogo de la apurada
individual no
en las dos y vamos por el oro
lamentablemente en el individual se nos
escapó pero acá gracias a la fortaleza
mis compañeros de equipo podemos
lograrlo creo que fue un combate muy
cambiante en algunos momentos nosotros
estamos arriba en otros momentos de
ellos pero creo que fue la fortaleza
mental lo que nos ayudó a mantener este
combate mantenernos acá presentes y
saber que cada toque era lo que contaba
y seguir trabajando por la victoria lo
hice en esta jornada